Hey David, can you address the issue that
came up on Joe Rogan's show when you were
interviewed, where Joe Equated with Steven
Crowder did to Carlos Mazda to what Sam Cedar
does to Dave Rubin?
Listen, I actually, in watching that back,
I think that people may have misunderstood.
I didn't interpret what Joe Rogan was doing
as actually equating the homophobic harassment
by Steven Crowder of Carlos Mazda to Sam Cedar
making videos about Dave Ruben.
But I do think that I missed an opportunity
to much more clearly sort of explore, explain
my position.
And the best way I can say it is when Sam
Cedar Critiques Dave Ruben, he's criticizing
Dave Rubin for what he says, not for who he
is.
Dave Rubin's identity plays no role in Sam
cedars critiques of Dave Rubin.
Dave Rubin happens to be Jewish.
Dave Rubin happens to be gay.
Dave Rubin happens to be male.
None of those characteristics have ever played
a role in Sam's criticisms of Dave Ruben when
Steven Crowder is including phrases like lispy
be Mexican queer when he is talking about
Carlos Mazda.
Even if you want to argue that the critique
was about Antifa as as uh, came up during
my Joe Rogan appearance, you are getting into
critiques that are critiques of who Carlos
Mazda is as a person.
And what, where is that coming?
I don't know what that is.
That is a very strange noise.
Apologies for that.
Uh, hopefully people didn't hear a very strange
ringing noise there.
Um, it's, I should have much more simply laid
out in that way during, um, during my appearance
with Rogan, which was to say the real difference
is that Sam is critiquing ideas and not including
identity, whereas Steven Crowder is going
hard on Carlos Mazda's identity and it just
so happens that that is a violation of youtube
terms and conditions.
So I apologize that I did not do as good of
a job as I could have.
You know, in the heat of the moment, it, you
always come up with better things to say after.
But my understanding was that most of the
conversation was not literally Joe saying
what Crowder did is the same as what Sam did,
but asking me what I thought the differences
were and I don't know that I did the best
job of explaining it at the time.
Uh, although it did lead to this funny moment
where I said, well, if you're saying that
Dave Rubin has a cognitive limitation, then
in a way, maybe Sam is going after him for
a disability, which of course is not what
I was saying.
And it's not what I thought Rogan was saying,
but it led to kind of a weird, funny moment.
A, we'll talk about that again and I think
that that is an issue that's going to come
up again on the program.
Make sure you get access to the bonus show
by becoming a member at www dot [inaudible].
Join
[inaudible] dot com or a patron at patrion.com/david
Pakman show